[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas fijaos en esta
noticia porque este vídeo tiene mucho
que ver con ella las acciones amenazan
la posición del reino unido- como patio
de recreo para los oligarcas rusos las
primeras sanciones contra los rusos
podrían afectar a lo que algunos llaman
el moscú sobre el támesis pero antes de
adentrarnos de lleno en este asunto os
hago una pregunta sabéis cuántos
millonarios hay en el mundo cinco
millones diez veinte quizás pues no
hablamos aproximadamente de más de 50
millones de millonarios en todo el
planeta pero quizás el dato más
impresionante es que en la inmensa
mayoría de los casos no hablamos de
herencias tres de cada cuatro
millonarios crearon su riqueza con su
trabajo pero alguna vez te has
preguntado dónde prefieren vivir cuáles
son los destinos favoritos de las
personas más adineradas bueno seguro que
ya sabéis por dónde van los tiros porque
si la ciudad con más millonarios de todo
el mundo no es nueva york ni singapur ni
dubai ni siquiera esa pequeña joya
llamada miami
londres
la capital británica cuenta con unas 900
mil personas cuyos patrimonios netos
superan el millón de dólares es decir
que si vais a londres aproximadamente
una de cada diez personas que veáis por
la calle tiene más de un millón de
dólares eso no es todo londres también
es la séptima ciudad del mundo con más
billonarios los llamados mega ricos en
torno al támesis viven más de 60
[Música]
sorprendidos no me extraña sobre todo
cuando caemos en que londres no es una
ciudad precisamente famosa por el sol
las playas y los mojitos el atardecer
así que la pregunta es qué diablos tiene
londres para atraer a tantos millonarios
vale la respuesta corta sería algo así
como alberto es obvio precisamente allí
es donde está el dinero y en cierto modo
sí es verdad londres es uno de los dos
grandes centros financieros a nivel
mundial el otro por cierto es nueva york
hablamos de una plaza donde confluyen
inversores procedentes de prácticamente
todos los rincones del mundo
si eres un gobierno o una gran empresa y
quieres conseguir grandes cantidades de
financiación seguramente te verás
obligado a visitar la capital británica
casi una quinta parte de todos los
préstamos bancarios internacionales y
más del 12% de todos los bonos
internacionales cotizados tienen su
origen en el reino unido además londres
también es la capital mundial de los
derivados y el lugar donde se lleva a
cabo más del 40 por ciento de toda la
negociación mundial de divisas y es que
hablamos de un enorme hub de servicios
financieros de todo tipo que también
acoge las sedes europeas de centenares
de multinacionales el llamado soft power
nos impuestos con medidos y una
regulación flexible y poco intrusiva
situado a londres en un epicentro
mundial de la actividad financiera
[Música]
no no
en otras palabras londres es un cohete
de hacer dinero ya la gente con dinero
le gustan los sitios donde puedan hacer
todavía más dinero al tiempo que
consiguió mantener sus fortunas seguras
vamos creo que no estamos descubriendo
la pólvora esto que os contamos tiene un
nombre y apellido seguridad jurídica el
ingrediente fundamental para que un país
prospere
pero no nos desviemos además de todos
estos motivos que son la clave que se
esconde tras el éxito de londres y en
general del reino unido- hay otro motivo
más que podemos destacar y que puede
muchos no conozcáis la llamada visa
'tier one' comúnmente conocida como visa
dorada una idea quizás brillante pero
que como todo tiene sus luces y sus
sombras y que ahora ha sido señalada
como una de las vías de castigo contra
rusia por la invasión de ucrania o mejor
dicho como una de las vías de castigo
contra los oligarcas que respaldan a
vladimir putin los legisladores de la
unión europea impulsarán la prohibición
de nuevos pasaportes dorados y visados
para los rusos en el gobierno de johnson
acaba con los visados de oro para los
oligarcas rusos la represión del reino
unido- contra los oligarcas rusos puede
significar el final de london grado las
élites ricas se ven obligadas a elegir
entre su riqueza su lujo su futuro y
apoyar a vladimir putin amigos amigas en
este vídeo os vamos a contar como el
reino unido se ha esforzado en atraer
millonarios procedentes de todos los
rincones del mundo y como esto se ha
convertido ahora en un enorme quebradero
de cabeza por culpa de las visas express
concedidas a cientos de oligarcas rusos
atentos
por cierto esto un momento antes de
continuar
[Música]
si hablamos sobre las repercusiones de
la invasión de ucrania no podemos dejar
de hablar de energía hace poco en visual
políticos contamos como azerbaiyán y
sobre todo türkmenistán podrían llegar a
convertirse a medio plazo en una
alternativa al gas de rusia pero claro
eso es algo que llevaría tiempo la
cuestión es que podría hacer europa a
corto plazo si rusia decidiera acortar
el suministro de gas es el gn l el gas
natural liquado una alternativa real
hasta qué punto podría suplir al gas
ruso pues bien para conocer la respuesta
a todas estas preguntas no os perdáis el
último vídeo de si lo hubiera sabido el
canal de información financiera de
mutuactivos os dejamos el link abajo en
la descripción
[Música]
la visa de los ricos
antes de nada un apunte importante las
visas doradas no son algo exclusivo del
reino unido- de hecho hay 23 países en
el mundo que tienen visas de este tipo
cada una con sus propias peculiaridades
[Música]
incluso países como grecia o españa que
no son precisamente conocidos por ser
los lugares más 'business friendly' de
la tierra cuentan con vistas de este
tipo ligadas a la inversión en activos
como inmuebles acciones o deuda pública
por ejemplo en españa' el modelo se
implantó en el año 2013 con el objetivo
de dar salida a muchos de los inmuebles
vacíos que quedaron sin vender cuando en
2008 comenzó a reventar la burbuja
inmobiliaria de esta forma en españa'
puedes comprar tu visa si adquieres
inmuebles por valor de al menos 500 mil
euros
de hecho tras el break sheet este se ha
convertido en un buen negocio para
españa y en general los países
mediterráneos digamos que muchos
británicos están planteando comprar
propiedades para obtener una visa y así
poder hacer negocios y entrar y salir de
países como españa sin más limitaciones
británicos ahora lee quién países de la
unión europea con visa dorada para
recuperar sus derechos de viaje que es
exactamente lo mismo que han hecho
también muchos rusos sólo hay que echar
un vistazo la costa del sol así que
llegados hasta aquí la pregunta que
muchos podéis haceros es entonces porque
centrarse únicamente en la visa dorada
del reino unido
[Música]
pues veréis lo cierto es que pocos
países han tenido a la vez tanto éxito y
tanta polémica con este tipo de
programas como el reino unido- desde su
implantación en el año 2008 más de 12
mil millonarios junto a sus familias han
visto como las puertas del reino unido-
se les abrían de par en par gracias a la
visa 'tier one'
[Música]
[Aplausos]
actualmente y tras varias modificaciones
y endurecimiento de los requisitos se
necesitan invertir al menos dos millones
de libras algo más de dos millones y
medio de dólares en compañías
registradas en el país o en bonos además
con este tipo de visas se puede optar a
la residencia permanente en un plazo
determinado de años que se acorta
conforme crece la cantidad de dinero
invertido
[Música]
si en cierto modo es algo así como
comprarte una visa y colarse en la lista
de solicitudes esa es en esencia la idea
si traes dinero e inversión al reino
unido- te abrimos las puertas de par en
par la cuestión que podemos hacernos es
qué tipo de impacto tienen estos
instrumentos sobre la vida económica
general si esta visa 'tier one' es o no
beneficiosa para el país
[Música]
según defiende el propio gobierno
británico el propósito de este tipo de
visas es incrementar la inversión y la
capitalización de las empresas
registradas en el reino unido- de esta
forma la economía gana competitividad y
crece la generación de empleos lo que
también beneficia a las clases medias y
trabajadoras cuantas más empresas hay
más robustas sean estas mejor para todos
así que la visa dorada británica puede
ser considerada como todo un elemento
dinamizador para la economía hablamos de
un instrumento que ha logrado atraer al
reino unido- decenas y decenas de miles
de millones de libras de inversión
productiva
por supuesto este tipo de instrumentos
también tienen sus puntos débiles muchos
detractores las critican por ser una
especie de salvoconductos para grandes
fortunas cuya riqueza puede haber sido
digamos obtenida de forma poco limpia
por decir algo en países donde el estado
de derecho y los controles brillan por
su ausencia por otra parte también
pueden actuar como un refugio para
muchas personas que consiguen gracias a
estas visas poder escapar tiranos de
todo tipo
[Música]
sea como sea la cuestión que hoy más nos
atañe es otra adivináis quienes han sido
los inversores más favorecidos por las
visas 'tier one' del reino unido-
321 exacto los chinos y los rusos sobre
todo los rusos estos últimos de hecho
han llegado a convertirse en todo un
quebradero de cabeza para downing
street- habéis escuchado hablar de
london grado atentos
él contó london grado
[Música]
en 2015 la cadena de televisión rusa sts
lanzó london grad una comedia de
televisión sobre una agencia
especializada en solucionar problemas a
los millonarios rusos que viven en
londres una trama que por muy random que
nos parezca en realidad no tiene nada de
aleatoria quizás ni siquiera sus
historias sean del todo descabelladas
[Música]
pero aproximadamente 12.000 titulares de
visas doradas británicas en torno a una
quinta parte son rusos esto
evidentemente tiene una explicación y
para ello hay que remontarse al periodo
2008-2015 este fue un período conocido
como fe ciega entonces los requisitos
del programa era - y sobre todo apenas
existían controles para saber quiénes
eran realmente los beneficiarios de las
visas doradas y de dónde procedía su
fortuna
y claro si mezclamos en una misma
coctelera estos tres ingredientes rusos
millonarios y pocos controles que crees
que no salen exacto los oligarcas
[Música]
de repente el modelo de visa tier one
británico se convirtió en todo un imán
para los oligarcas rusos tanto es así
que en los 7 años que transcurrieron
entre el 2008 y el 2015 se otorgaron el
85 por ciento de todas las visas doradas
a inversores rusos pero claro cuando se
endurecieron los requisitos el flujo de
llegada desde la madre patria a rusia se
ralentizó mucho desde 2015 los rusos ya
sólo suponen el 15 por ciento de las
visas concedidas si sigue siendo un
porcentaje enorme pero ya no es tan loco
seguro que nos sorprende es como si a
buena parte de los millonarios rusos que
buscaban invertir y poder vivir en reino
unido- no les hiciera mucha gracia que
os me hacen en sus asuntos no sé por qué
pero seguro seguro que me da que nos
sorprenden
[Música]
el caso es que hubo un momento en que el
gobierno británico se dio cuenta de que
algo estaba yendo mal rematadamente mal
básicamente porque el país se estaba
llenando de oligarcas amigos de vladimir
putin y con ellos también se estaba
incrementando el peso de las inversiones
rusas ligadas al gobierno del kremlin en
la economía británica por ejemplo según
la organización transparencia
internacional desde 2016 más de 1500
millones de libras de activos
inmobiliarios han sido comprados en el
país por altos funcionarios y oligarcas
rusos vinculados al kremlin y lo cierto
es que la cifra real teniendo en cuenta
la opacidad con la que operan podría ser
muchísimo mayor y por supuesto esto es
tan sólo un ejemplo
así que podéis creernos cuando os
decimos que esto desde el punto de vista
geoestratégico no es la mejor idea por
no hablar de que muchas de esas personas
están acostumbradas a hacer y deshacer a
su antojo no sólo sobre sus cosas sino
también sobre las de los demás para
ellos cosas como el estado de derecho la
competencia o los negocios libres pues
qué queréis que os diga suenan a
imperfecciones fruto de los blandengues
occidentales una cultura que tampoco es
precisamente buena para el clima general
de los negocios incluso existen informes
que denuncian que muchos de estos
oligarcas han intentado influir en la
política británica es decir lo mismo que
hacen en la propia rusia ya sabéis
cuestión de costumbres
[Música]
así que en 2015 las autoridades
británicas comenzaron a cambiar y
endurecer las condiciones de acceso al
tiempo que mejoraron los controles e
incluso se inició una investigación
retroactiva sobre más de 6 mil visas
doradas si no nos hemos equivocado
alrededor de la mitad de todas las visas
emitidas han sido o están siendo
revisadas y se está investigando a sus
titulares ahí está por ejemplo el caso
de roman abramovich
[Aplausos]
abrahamowicz es un conocido oligarca
ruso propietario de un club de fútbol de
londres el chelsea en 2018 retiró la
solicitud de renovación de esta visa
porque cada vez le estaban investigando
más sus negocios al final optó por la
ciudadanía israelí también tenemos el
caso de alexander pd britney un
millonario ruso que entró a reino unido
a través de su esposa y luego se le
otorgó una visa dorada a pesar de que en
ese momento estaba siendo investigado
por la interpol por fraude lavado de
dinero y abuso de poder
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pero no solo podemos encontrar rusos en
esa polémica lista también tenemos a
personajes como el indio edad modi un
millonario que está inmerso en un
proceso de extradición por lavado de
dinero y por supuestamente haber
perpetrado un fraude de 2000 millones de
dólares contra el banco envió p n veo un
montón de millonarios políticos y
oligarcas kazajos ucranianos e incluso
bangladesh y estamos lo mejor de cada
casa todos ellos tienen en común haber
recibido su visa durante el período
conocido como fe ciega ahora bien la
persecución la investigación a los
millonarios rusos en el reino unido se
ha vuelto aún más dura desde 2018
alguien recuerda que sucedió en
reinounido ese año fijaos rusos
adinerados en gran bretaña se enfrentan
a nuevas medidas después de salisbury
exacto en 2018 es cuando se produjo el
envenenamiento del ex espía ruso serguéi
skripal y su hija envenenados con no
[ __ ] por dos agentes rusos
el novillo para los que no lo sepáis es
un veneno ruso desarrollado en la era
soviética os dejamos por cierto en la
descripción un vídeo donde os contamos
todos los detalles sobre cómo se emplea
el veneno en la rusia moderna el caso es
que el reino unido- se dio cuenta de que
la presencia de oligarcas rusos próximos
al presidente putin podía terminar
convirtiéndose incluso en todo un
problema de seguridad nacional el
estatus de londres como el patio de
recreo de oligarcas conectados al
kremlin socava la postura dura del reino
unido- con rusia gran bretaña no es el
único país en el que los oligarcas
guardan dinero y los rusos son los
únicos que depositan dinero ilícito en
el extranjero pero la crisis de ucrania
ha llevado al gobierno británico que a
tratar de resolver las contradicciones
entre su política exterior y la escasa
supervisión de londres reino unido fue
decidido a la hora de imponer sanciones
a rusia sin embargo no fue tan ágil con
los oligarcas esto es algo que incluso
ha denunciado el diario conservador the
times fijaos desde marzo de 2022 el
progreso dilatorio del reino unido- con
las sanciones empieza a ser una fuente
de vergüenza y un tema de inquietud
política editorial del diario the times
pensad que el dinero de los grandes a
rusos vinculados al kremlin ha
enriquecido entre otros muchos a bufetes
de abogados banqueros arquitectos y
empresarios de la hostelería y el sector
del lujo auténtica dopamina económica
que ralentiza la toma de decisiones
difíciles
[Música]
sea como sea está claro que esta vez
todo es diferente y que el paraíso
británico y en general europeo para las
grandes fortunas rusas puede estar
llegando a su fin no hay lugar para el
dinero sucio en el reino unido se ha
avisado a los que respaldan a putin no
habrá lugar donde ocultan sus ganancias
mal habidas boris johnson primer
ministro del reino unido pero llegó
hasta aquí turno para ti crees que un
sistema de visa dorada sería beneficioso
para tu país debería filtrarse a los
beneficiarios o por contra deberían
estar abiertos a cualquier inversor
déjanos tu opinión por aquí debajo en
los comentarios y ahora si este vídeo te
resultado interesante no olvides darle
al botón de like y suscribir te avisa al
político así como darle a la campanita
para recibir una notificación y no
perderte ninguno de nuestros vídeos un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]